nach monatelanger corona pause kehrt die
klimabewegung friday future auf die
straße zurück die aktivistinnen und
aktivisten rufen zum vierten globalen
klima streik auf aber sind solche
proteste mit vielen menschen das
richtige zeichen gerade jetzt wo die
korona zahlen in vielen ländern wieder
steigen ja das war keine leichte
entscheidung für uns verdächtig weil wir
sagen ja kalt er wie crysis benehmen die
wissenschaft ernten ihrem stand befand
sich auch das umfrage sondern der
menschen ja ganz ganz wichtig dass unser
oberster stelle kommt und wir haben uns
aber dennoch entschieden aufzurufen zum
streik trotz aller schwierigkeiten eben
weil die lage so schlimm ist die streiks
sollen natürlich anders aussehen als vor
der pandemie corona konto indem wir neue
aktionsform überlegt die korona konform
sind
wir haben mittel und wege in großartigen
ausmaß in bewegung gesetzt um gedichtes
gedränge zu vermeiden um wirklich sicher
zu gehen menschen die bei uns
mitarbeiten sind sicher es wird nur
gestreift mit maske für abstand gehalten
für jeden streit gibt es sagen einer ein
umfassendes hygiene konzept das geht
dafür garantieren wir in dem sender muss
hier niemand garantieren kann das auf
das klima hier rauskommen ansprechen was
auch die abwägung die korona krise hatte
die klimabewegung rundum greta thunberg
kalt erwischt
für eine massenbewegung die schule
streik organisiert ist natürlich eine
pandemie die weder machen noch vor
öffnung ermöglicht ein großartiger
einschnitt nun soll die aufmerksamkeit
von politik und gesellschaft nach
monaten wieder auf die bedrohung durch
die klimakrise gelenkt werden
wir stellen fest die klimakrise
offensichtlich nie wirklich ernst
genommen wurde dann wie dieses aussieht
wie eine krise ernst genommen wird da
haben wir in baku ronal lebt das könnte
mich jetzt wahnsinnig frustrierend ich
kann auf dem boden stampfen und würden
seinen sagen meint pia die klima stimmt
jedoch nicht ernst genommen
ich war gar nicht hilfreich was ich
daraus mitnehmen oder was wir daraus
mitnehmen sollten oder können
einverständnis darüber wie es
funktionieren kann das training ernst
nehmen
nun soll also auch die klimakrise
richtig ernst genommen werden
dafür will frey dsv future in den
nächsten monaten wieder richtig laut
werden